he had a muslim testify for him in court
which is true
and he achieved great position of
prominence in islamic society
which is true he was the physician to
even to salvadine i believe by the end
of his career
but even maimonides someone who we look
at as an example of somebody who
existing
at a high level in islamic society when
he's writing to his
own people he's honest and he says
the the the muslims have inflicted
persecution
upon us they we have suffered greatly
his words are
no nation has um persecuted us more
than this nation okay so this is clearly
clearly
and even you put forward the argument
that's been faith the fact that this has
been
universally accepted by jews as being
part of the narrative
suggests there must be a remnant of
truth in there
that there was persecution of jews in
muslim society
now let's get on to what is that
persecution okay
you made two points yeah i made two
points and then you made two characters
now you said and maybe this is where we
can make it a little more engaging
because the big long
speeches don't really help any of us
engage the viewers i agree
so i'm gonna say i can give categoric
examples of where i'm persecuted against
in a caliphate that's run according to
sharia according to the sunnah of
muhammad and my best example
easiest example zakat zakat is fixed
yeah there is a fixed amount of money
that the muslims pay
jizya is not fixed jizya is dependent
upon whatever the caliph
decides that the jew is going to pay or
the person of the book is going to pay
now under some caliphate that was a
reasonable amount
and it does say that the poor don't have
to pay
the the jizya but if they're not poor
then it's down to the the color to
determine what the jews pay what the
christians pay
and that is separate from what the
muslims pay and it can be a lot
more and it can be less it really
depends on the caliphate and so when you
segregate a society
and you say muslims pay this tax and
non-muslims pay another tax
that ultimately is an example of
discrimination
that has been abused throughout history
okay great points
now coming back to the letter of
maimonides first of all we need to show
whether the letter is actually authentic
even if it is authentic let's assume for
for
for the sake of the argument maimonides
actually
wrote that letter there is no problem in
it i'll tell you why
maimonides has been severely persecuted
by
a muslim group called al-muhad
al-muahidoon
if a person who was tortured
or persecuted by isis today and was to
write a letter about muslims
i wouldn't blame him i wouldn't blame
him for for assuming
that i am being persecuted by muslims
because these people have the appearance
of muslims
unfortunately right now maimonides the
question is
when he wrote this letter where
was he writing this letter from egypt
egypt
okay now what period of his
egyptian existence was this
was it was this the early period when he
had recently come from spain
having been persecuted and put through
all that or was it actually after he had
become the physician to the sultan
himself
okay if maimonides writing maimonides is
writing this letter after he's a
physician to the sultan
the doctors of the sultan then there are
two options here
either he is lying about his condition
because how can you be the physician to
the sultan the doctor to the sultan the
to the king himself
and say our condition is very bad and it
is very
possible that he was lying why because
why is he writing this letter
and who is he writing this letter to
according to what joseph read
this letter was being written to a
jewish group of people in yemen
who were considering accepting islam
who were contemplating becoming muslims
and
his job as rambam
or the second moses or the
the shepherd of the flock uh you know
if you like his job was to sway them to
put them off
to push them away from islam and to say
all those things
it does exactly that these people are
barbarians they're persecutors we're not
happy with them
don't accept islam therefore so all
these things put together
one can easily contextualize the letter
but looking at the
bigger picture now it is very clear that
joseph accepted that maimonides
definitely had a high position in muslim
societies
if the jews were persecuted as he
claimed
earlier why would a jew be a physician
to the sultan
why would a jewish person be given that
position
and such a sensitive position who is the
physician someone who's checking your
pulse
someone is prescribing medicine for you
even possibly giving you medicine
he can easily poison the sulphur and
kill him why would the sultan
trust a jewish man and not only any
ordinary jewish man
a rabbi of that repute a rabbi of that
status
someone who is known as the second moses
among the jews later on actually
so let's not be anachronistic about
history so it is very clear that he had
a high position now it doesn't stop
there
we can look at other jewish testimonies
from spain now very quickly no no
yeah let me finish this yeah very
quickly here there was a jewish rabbi
called
by bin pakuda have you heard of him yes
you know yeah writing
in cordoba 1080s he writes
that our living condition is not
the same as the muslims it is better
than theirs
we are more prosperous than the muslims
are
under the rule of the arabs
there you go that's one testimony let's
fast forward less force
yes let's fast forward yeah let's fast
forward
okay we have for example in the ninth
century
okay there is uh an anonymous jewish
source a commentary on the torah okay
it's called
petra safran petra safran karen
armstrong
she refers to this book in her history
of jerusalem
and she states that this anonymous
author jewish author
wrote about the conditions of the jewish
people in
jerusalem in the 9th century during the
abbasid period
he states that we have been honored by
the ishmaelites
that we worship together the same god in
this holy place
in other words he was praising the
condition of the jewish people under
islamic domain then we have other
testimonies from
i'm giving you different dynasties very
quickly because time is running out
and joseph needs to talk about this yeah
and i've written an article on this by
the way this is why i know these sources
yeah
um then we move forward to the ottoman
period
when jerusalem was governed by the
ottomans
to be very precise during the reign of
sultan
suleiman the magnificent who governed
from 1520 to 1566 if i'm not mistaken
right he governed 46 years during his
reign the the jewish people
flourished in jerusalem how do we know
this a scholar
named amnon cohen amnon
cohen who published in his book in 1994
and the book is titled a world from
within
the court records from
the the islamic court of jerusalem in
this in these two volumes
he discusses the history of the jewish
cases
are you listening everyone jewish cases
filed
within the islamic court of jerusalem so
he studied cases from the year 1500 to
70 years of cases he studied he came up
with 1000 jewish cases filed in the
sharia court
filed by the jewish people voluntarily
and amnon cohen being a jewish scholar
from israel
he was he wanted to know why the jews
were doing that why were they going
to the sharia court even though they had
their best dens
they had their own jewish courts uh
in jerusalem but he states this is a
jewish israeli scholar
in 1994 he states based upon a study
this was because the jews expected
justice to come quicker
from the sharia court than their own
courts and cases vary from
uh uh from uh for example
from uh a case about nafaka what we call
you know provisions if a wife has been
divorced and she needs provisions from
the husband
and there are other domestic cases being
discussed in this courts
so his conclusion is that the jews of
jerusalem in the 16th century
were more prosperous than the muslims
were perfect
okay okay wait wait wait wait of course
of course of course joseph
don't do it i'm i'm finishing
i'm finishing because this topic is so
important and
yeah i'm coming back i'm coming back to
zakat issue okay
so this is these examples from different
dynasties in different periods different
places show you what
general pattern of muslim behavior
was kind generous
and and harmonious towards the jews
right the jewish people flourished
in different ways i can give you
examples of joseph joseph please i was
very patient listening to you be patient
with me as well
i know some of this information is is
difficult to to to fathom but
no i'm giving references a wrong wrong
right
and most references i gave are from
jewish sources by the way
even bernie lewis someone like bernard
lewis a staunch zionist
who advised the us government to attack
iraq in 2003
even him in his book jews of islam
acknowledges
that the muslims treated the jews
with generosity in comparison to what
was happening to them in christian
europe
okay so and over a thousand years
bernard lewis states
for over a thousand years jews survived
extinction
due to muslim protection for over a
thousand years and he also states
ninety percent of the jewish population
of the world
survived destruction under the
protection of islam and muslims
bernard lewis again my references are
very clear go and check
and come back to me if i'm lying okay
now next point zakat can we come back
no no no no no you raised it you raised
it please be patient with me i'm
finishing very soon and you can come
back
i will listen to you patiently no you
can't come in because it's me and joseph
okay so zakat issue now joseph made a
claim that uh zakat is fixed and jesus
is not fixed
actually that's not true as well because
in our earliest
sources we are told firstly the primary
rule
to deal with the non-muslims what is the
primary rule in bukhari
in bukhari we have a statement from the
second caliph of islam
omar bin khattab omar was the second
caliph of islam
and what did the public say about him
upon you is my way in the way of my
rightly guided
caliphs who were they omar is one of
them so we have to follow him umar
upon his deathbed when his stomach was
split open
dying man he advised he advised for his
successor
he stated whoever succeeds me beware of
the rights of the
non-muslims do not over burden them
do not put a burden upon them more than
they can be um
the second caliph of islam the words of
a dying man
right these words were directly relevant
to the jewish people
okay because who was he talking about he
was talking about the jews and the
christians
okay so what is jizya jizya is one
gold coin per year it is clearly stated
in fortune
imam imam buladuri's
the conquest of lands in that book there
are documents
that clearly state that the jizya is one
gold coin
every year which is four grams of gold
in current value
200 pounds a year so if there is a
millionaire
jewish merchant who has a million pounds
in his bank account
in theory theoretically according to the
islamic
sources he has to pay 200 pounds a year
every year
if a muslim has a million pound in his
bank account he must pay
2.5 which is 25 000 pounds where is
justice in that
i as a muslim can stand up here and say
you know what islam is actually not just
to the muslim people islam is more just
to the jewish people
the he the jewish merchant has to pay
200 pounds
every year even though he may have a
million pounds in his bank account
but me i have to give 25 25 000
pounds over or for a million pounds now
this is
theoretically the earliest islamic
sources what happened later on
no doubt sources are abused they were
misused
even today groups like isis and other
extremist entities are using
sources to abuse the jewish people are
doing it
is the state of israel is abusing
misusing the jewish sources so we have
extremists
we have unpleasant characters we have we
have people who abuse our sources
throughout our history jews are the jews
did it muslims did it christians did it
so the good thing about us me and joseph
is that we are brother brothers in that
thought
why because he also believes that there
are extremist jews
who do extreme things and abuse the
sources i also believe that there are
muslims where extremist muslims will
abuse the sources
now over to you sorry do do apologize
for long
long long story
what i want to point out is what just
happened then so
we went to the al muhart and we agreed
on the alma had they're not good muslims
we then you brought a proof which was
maimonides and we then established that
actually your understanding of
maimonides maybe isn't the jewish
understanding of maimonides
and the jewish understanding of
maimonides is that he was persecuted
under islam you then went through some
very
um a lot of material that i haven't
heard of so you mentioned petrus effort
never heard of it in my life so we're
now talking very fringe
sources which most jews are not familiar
with so i will go away bernard lewis
bernard lewis is he's a historian he's
got nothing to do with
the actual jewish historian i'm talking
about source material i'm talking about
the source material
um and then you mentioned and you went
you went to the 16th
ottomans in israel now i would encourage
anybody to dive into google 1517
massacre of jews in hebron the jews were
massacred by ottomans
in hebron in israel and so again at a
time when you've given
us jews having a
good head straight down straight the
massacre um
at a time when jews were supposed to not
be persecuted
there's a clear evidence of not just
persecution but a massacre
taking place in the very land you said
it was supposed to be amazing
now i'm not you've said a lot of truth
there were jews that did achieve
great positions including maimonides in
islamic society
but achieving a high position in some
islamic societies
does not mean that jews are being tried
well throughout islamic islam
history douche that jewish understanding
if you speak to any of the jews from the
middle east
almost all of them will universally tell
you that they
suffered in modern history and in
ancient history
and so i believe jews and muslims can
and will coexist i think we have more in
common than that divides us
and i think we do have a rich history of
coexistence
but i think there needs to be a
recognition from many muslims
that history isn't as they see it
through these rose-tinted glasses
but their ancestors have inflicted pain
upon my ancestors
and you can go right the way back to
muhammad you can go back to the battle
of the trenches
you can go back to the beheading of jews
you can go but from the very very
beginning
there has been persecution now you can
justify that and say they were
treacherous they betrayed muhammad
therefore
but you're doing it for me but to this
day
to this day because of a battle that
took place
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
years ago i a jew
i'm not allowed to step foot in mecca
and medina i am not allowed to live
in arabia omar who's quoted often as
being one of the best caliphs for the
jewish people
omar kicked the jews out of arabia it
was omar that pushed the mountain he
actually sent them to iran in israel and
he sent others to i forgot
i'm terrible with middle eastern
geography
people can look up you're making you're
making a lot of points and it's going to
take me a long time to respond to all of
them so if you don't want a long
response
keep it short and i'll keep it short
okay yeah because you're strength omar
you're throwing jews in um so
you're throwing a lot of things all i'm
doing is saying and it's a very simple
statement
that anybody who believes that the
jewish existence under islam
was consistently good is consistently
stupid
there has been good times and bad times
there have been good muslims
and bad muslims good jews and bad jews
um
now to bring it back to the jews here
you said no no no
you didn't let me do this no no problem
can you carry on down but my response is
going to be
try i'm trying to keep mine as brief as
possible because for the sake of the
engagement of the audience
okay no no go on long extensively talk
about all the things i mentioned all the
all the sources i gave what's your
response to those sources
so to be honest i would have to go away
and read them so i know the epistle i
know my money
as well so if if what i'm saying is true
you'll you're going to come back
you're going to come back and confirm
everything i said